what we're going to do in this video is
look at pairs of figures and see if they
are scaled copies of each other so for
example in this diagram is figure b a
scaled version of figure a pause the
video and see if you can figure that out
so there's multiple ways that you could
approach this one way is to say well
let's see what the scaling factor would
be so we could look at this length side
length so this side right over here has
length 3 on figure a this side length
right over here has length
one two three four five
this side length has length five as well
this has length five
this length we could figure it out with
the pythagorean theorem but i'll i won't
even look at that one just yet but let's
look at corresponding sides so to go
from this side if we scale up the
corresponding side to that would be this
side
right over here and what is its length
well its length when you scale it up
looks like five
so to go from three
to five
you would have to multiply by
five thirds
five thirds but let's look at
this side now
so it's five in figure a what length is
it in figure b
well it is one two three four five it's
still five so to go from five to five
you have to multiply by 1. and so you
have a different scaling factor for
corresponding or what could have been
corresponding sides this side right over
here you're scaling up by 5 3 while this
bottom side this base right here you're
not scaling at all so these actually are
not scaled versions of each other
let's do another example
so in this example is figure b a scaled
version of figure a pause the video and
see if you can figure it out
all right well we're going to do the
same exercise and here they've given us
the measures of the different sides so
this side has length 2.
this side has length the corresponding
side or what could be the corresponding
side has length 6 to go from two to six
you have to multiply by three
if we look at
these two potentially corresponding
sides that side and that side
once again to go from four to twelve you
would multiply by three
so that is looking good as well
now to go from
this side down here this has length six
the potentially corresponding side right
over here has length 14. well here we're
not multiplying by 3. if these were
scaled a figure b was a scaled-up
version of figure a we would multiply by
3. but 6 times 3 is not 14 it's 18. so
these actually are not figure b is not a
scaled version of figure a let's do one
more example
so once again pause this video and see
if figure b is a scaled version of
figure a
so we're going to do the same exercise
let's look at potentially corresponding
sides so that side to that side
to go from 4 to 12
we would multiply by 3
and then we could look at
this side
and this side
to go from 4 to 12.
once again you multiply by 3 so that's
looking good so far
we could look at this side and this side
potentially corresponding sides once
again we're going from 4 to 12
multiplying by 3 looks good so far
and then we could look at
this side
and this side
2.2 to 6.6 once again
multiplying by 3 looking really good and
then we only have one last one to check
2.2
to 6.6 once again
multiplying by 3. so all of the side
lengths have been scaled up by 3 so we
can feel pretty good that figure b is
indeed a scaled up representation of
figure a